[Music]
hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
right now i'm standing in sunderland
outside a huge massive 28 bedroom
apartment block this apartment block in
sunderland was so run down that no one
wanted to buy it no one wanted to rent
it the developer was really motivated to
get it rented or get it shifted this was
a perfect opportunity for a deal to be
done and guess what one of my students
pete he spoke to the owner he has
managed to secure it on a no money down
lease option agreement basis he's done a
refurb using
zero of his own money and right now
today it's fully let he's making 4 000
pounds a month cash flow profit from it
and he has the option to buy it down the
line and make a load of money on capital
appreciation too if you want to learn
exactly how pete did this stay tuned
because i'm going to be picking his
brain and figuring out how he's
structured this deal let's go hey hey
this is my man pete she's here how are
you doing i'm good man i'm good
congratulations on this cool thanks so
much huge so this is pete so pete man
huge congratulations thank you bud so
you got the whole thing full yeah that's
it so we ain't all of this
huge man yeah so listen i know when you
took this on
inside it was a little bit of a wreck
yeah how much of your own money have you
used on the refurb the legal paperwork
how much have you had to put in zero
nothing yeah okay so which is what i
want to be picking your brain on how
you've structured it how you financed it
how much you're making what a lease
option agreement is yeah show me around
man how long have you lived here
um
oh just a month how are you finding it i
love it oh that's good is he a good
manager
thanks for letting us film around as
well we appreciate you so much you've
done a lot as well even this area here
right just what did this used to be so
when we first got these this whole area
this whole yard was roughly about this
height just in weeds
nine skips all together so the the owner
then his situation yeah what what why
did he want to pass this on to you
it's a big project but the owner has got
he's a big portfolio landlord right for
him this was on the lower end of his
portfolio she's got a lot of big stuff
yeah it was just like a big headache to
him because of all the weeds and the way
it was run down let's have a look at it
see what you've done so what's happened
in here then so the kitchen was already
installed but um the probably been empty
for around three years yes um so that
landlord must have been tired man yeah
yeah and they probably had a few issues
i think whilst it was empty you know
like crime and you know things like that
yeah and it just become a real headache
for him yeah so he wanted somebody to
you know take it off of his hands yeah
manage it
what was your situation when you started
like what's your kind of backstory so i
didn't have any money to put into an
actual deal myself
but my back story is i've lived in a lot
of properties growing up moved around
quite a lot
i went through a care system when a
young person's care system
and trying to get out of that care
system it was really really hard i felt
really let down
um so
my sort of mission is i want to do that
a lot better when you started out like a
year or two back and you didn't really
have any money background in care and
stuff yeah yet you're still invested in
the training yeah why did what how did
that happen
i've always like been a positive person
you know positive mindset and believe in
self-development i think i found your
book
buy low
rent height yeah and then you know your
youtube channel and then did the dfe
course yeah and then um invested in the
dsm yeah and you know at the time i
didn't have the money but i knew i had
to do it right you know i knew i had to
do it and from that
um i've got this place and that's the
thing when you invest in yourself like
tony my man here tony so you're
obviously one of the mentors through the
training what and you've invested
everything into the deal on the basis
that pete found it people put the sweat
equity in yeah so from your perspective
what was it that made you want to invest
in this deal and also in pete yeah so
you know i'm one of the the mentors with
yourself with samuel leeds and um
met pete
um helped you along
and i sort of bought into you you know
um i loved your story i love where
you're coming from and you know it it
was heartfelt and i and i appreciate it
and i knew you put the sweat the sweat
into it you know you you worked hard on
this man yeah this was a wreck and i'm
looking forward to seeing what it looks
like now yeah but so i really bought
into pete you know bought into what and
so when he came up with and sort of
talked about this deal
i thought yeah it's a great deal because
i know initially it was going to be a
rental rental yeah and then you sort of
spoke to the owner flipped it around
talk to me about the figures then so
what what's the what is the deal what's
the landlord getting what are you
getting what's peak getting has been
structured so pete came to me with a
rent-to-rent option that the landlord
wanted he was tired he's got some much
bigger projects on on the go so this one
a guaranteed rent yeah and then you
could keep it shot of it yeah so they've
been been vacant for three years it had
rising dams so what did you agree what
did you agree with the landlord okay so
so he wanted 650 for the for the four
blocks uh for the whole thing for the
whole massive floor man 650 000 yep and
he wanted he wanted a
you know
either to sell it or he wanted a
guaranteed rent yeah so we we looked at
this and i thought well pete it'd be
better if we actually rather than the
rent to rent we'd propose a lease option
to him so
where we could buy the property in seven
years time
and just pay the pay the landlord a
guaranteed rent okay so you so you've
got the option to buy it as a joint
venture 50 50
you're going to be have the option to
buy it for 650 yeah but you've done it
all up you're renting out is fully left
what's the value now today as we're
filming okay so we've had a value
recently at now 800k since the work's
been done oh so 150 thousand pounds
uplift already yeah that's incredible so
effectively a buy refurbished finance
yeah yeah and it's fully rented and the
rent is what's the full rent on the
whole block just under 10k 10 000.
and and what are the costs what are all
the running costs you've got to pay the
landlord you've got the all the you know
maintenance management yeah so after all
of our costs our net profit is around 40
so we take
um about four grand four grand and you
split that 50 50 that's your profit
clear profit oh man right show me around
let's have a look
uh
[Music]
okay so
this is
just an example of one of the rooms so
the whole the whole building is tenanted
so we won't be able to go in all the
rooms because some of the tenants are in
across it but this is a standard room
it's pretty basic
um we've got laminate flooring which is
already included
all these walls we whitewashed
all of these walls they're all magnolia
all the skirts were yellow so we've you
know done all of that this is a complete
transformation isn't it i mean the
carpets as well they look new yeah the
carpets are all brand new um in
all of the properties they were bright
red like a royal red oh no and rent-wise
then so i know this is one of the
smallest rooms how much rent are you
getting per room yeah so the rents they
range from
330 up to 350. it just depends on what
size yeah and there's in total 28. 28
huge so guys tell us what refurb you've
had to do because i know you've spent a
lot of time and energy and sweat
refurbishing the place yep and the
standard is decent it's not high
standard yeah but it looks presentable
how long did the refurb take and how did
you sort of manage that process okay so
the first reefer we've got four units so
the first refurb took me 10 days to do
uh top to bottom um it's quick yeah
and then you put some tenants in we put
tennis and then the rent started paying
for more of the refurb and you staged it
on yeah nice yeah so it's been
kind of self-funded a little bit yeah
because the rent has been paying for
other parts of the refurb yeah we were
lucky enough we had one tenant who
wanted to pay nine months up front as
well nice yeah so that really helped and
how much did the refurb cost tony
because i know you put the money in for
all of this yeah talk to me about the
costs about the rent to the landlord
about the option fee give me the figures
so so basically the landlord uh wanted
4k
to do the deal right we paid we paid the
legals on both sides obviously the place
had been vacant for three and a half
years and needed a lot of work done to
it the all the boilers were were not
working
um so
i said landlord well if you do if you do
the rising damp if you sort the boilers
out we'll do we'll do all the um the
decorations
the cosmetics the carpet the decoration
did he do that yes he did right so that
was the first first thing that he agreed
to the second thing we agreed to is well
okay it's going to take some time to get
the place staged and up and running so
we wanted a rent-free period so we
negotiated a three and a half month rent
so for three and a half months you paid
zero rent
that's kind of cool and then you had
tenants within 10 days funding part of
the refurb negotiations it's important
to be able to negotiate how helpful was
it having tony and not just as the
investor but also as the mentor
consultant to kind of like help with the
negotiations yeah it's really really
useful that's um like why you know i
approached tony was for his advice and
expertise really um you know i had i
knew i had the vision and a drive but
there were certain aspects that i knew i
needed a partner for an experienced
partner yeah and tony's filled that oh
sorry
so you can come through if you want
we're just filming
that's all right
so obviously they're all full so we
can't go in um but how much money does
she pay 340. and this room is 350 this
room 350. so the rent's rolling in nice
now and the block so there's four blocks
is there yeah and there's seven rooms in
each block there's seven rooms in each
block right three bathrooms
one level total ten grand so in
sunderland center what's the like demand
like we're getting rooms rented because
that's something that can be if you're
taking on a 28 bedroom yeah project yeah
if you've got 20
void periods you can eat out your profit
well that was you know is a large
project so we were concerned
sunderland's big on students so a lot of
our tenants are students and there's
certain windows throughout the year and
we were concerned we were going to miss
a window but um yeah the demand has just
been overwhelming at that point yeah my
spare room is just going off the hook
i've had to turn it off not even a good
ad bro
it's one one picture i took this picture
so you filled the whole property with
that took this picture once
it was getting like 15 20 calls a day
literally wow yeah so to turn it off it
shows you've created a good product yeah
um our listing for the last 90 days that
hold some messages for so you can see
oh my goodness ridiculous
so you could probably you could probably
rent this 10 times over easy
easy
fair play guys
[Music]
so what's been the biggest challenge in
this project has it been worth it oh
it's definitely been worth it yeah um
i think the biggest challenge has been
out is being
what was staying motivated each day yeah
my to-do list was not just one to-do
list but multiple multiple to these
lists um so yeah it was the challenge
for me was just staying focused right
and going through
like the next step and then the next a
lot to do though you're doing a great
job yeah and tony obviously you've not
had to do anything
no but i'll support backup support
system yeah but the structure of your
joint venture presumably you put the
money in yeah which is twenty thousand
yeah which isn't a huge amount
considering that you've already made or
you've agreed to buy it for 650 and it's
already 850 that's 150 grand profit in
seven years time i imagine that it's
going to be even a lot more because the
area is absolutely yeah booming at the
moment isn't it yeah
what's your what's your reason then what
is it that gets you through the day what
is it that kind of because you viewed
almost 200 houses yeah you started with
nothing you invested into the training
and done this you've elbow greased it
like what's what what's the what's your
motivation for doing this um
it's
i want to create a care company and
that's like it's all mining tony's
vision really is to create this care
company
um the long-term vision of it is
to
provide the initial care and then
the after accommodation so when people
leave care as well why do you care about
that
because i went through it myself and it
was very very hard to get out of the
initial um care
sort of
aspect right and into private lats as
well it was very very hard at the time
to
get the money yeah um
secure a job whilst living in care as
well because then you have to start
paying so you want to be able to give
back and help those same people yeah
yeah amazing great great deal but
the secret of this of this uh property
is this
land over here he's part of the um
the purchase of the of the 650 000 pound
of the lease option is obviously the
entire block yeah but if you look over
here
this bill land comes with it as well
okay now this bill land has already got
lapsed uh planning fishing to build a
five uh five bedroom apartment on
a five bedroom apartment block yes
and was this part of the valuation 800
000 pounds no but you also have control
of this you've got score controls 650
all including the land absolutely
nice yeah that's what you really put
free up in we'll put pre-app in shortly
see how the land lies obviously because
it is a lapse uh planning mission we'll
see things changing you're gonna make a
fortune on this yeah i'm not sure if
you've noticed as well but this building
just here behind us yeah is the
university of sunderland right and these
are students in here aren't they all
students so no wonder we rent that so
quickly area and size
well done fantastic almost fall out of
bed yeah exactly literally one minute
away so
well well done thanks very much well i
just want to say as well thanks to tony
for believing in me uh for backing me
and you know sharing the same vision as
me um you know we've got a long term
goal together um we've been through a
lot of challenges on this project
already
but yeah thanks very much thank you for
everything you've done for me
um you know i can't thank you enough and
for you as well samuel if it wasn't for
you and everything that you put out for
everyone a lot of it free as well yeah
you know it's amazing what you do so
like
so many hours i've gone into it yeah if
it wasn't for that then i wouldn't have
this place i wouldn't have met tony i've
met hundreds and hundreds of people
through the training um you know my
knowledge has gone up i feel confident i
can hold my own in front of
yeah you know investors yeah you know
but so yeah i just want to say thank you
thank you so much
well done and well done tony as well and
how how good has pete been on the
project it's been brilliant you know
really fantastic jv partnered with guys
of course
for any better yeah i'm really grateful
i can help out pete you know i've been
mentoring you for some time now uh you
see you struggling a little bit trying
to help you that's the thing that we we
invest in people that invest in
themselves absolutely you make one step
we make ten yeah yeah you know hopefully
so well done p absolute legend rockstar
guys as well i hope you've been inspired
by this i hope you've learned a lot if
you want to do deals like this you know
you want to secure even if you've got no
money like you have no money if you've
got the knowledge if you invest a bit in
yourself you take action you're prepared
to put some sweat equity and work into
it guess what happens people will invest
in you so hopefully i'll see you guys
soon on the channel securing buildings
as big as this and as profitable as this
as well if you enjoy the channel hit
like drop a comment below subscribe you
want to see more videos like this you
can check them out right here and we'll
see you next time
[Music]